it was once rare for Supreme Court
nominations to become partisan standoffs
Ruth Bader Ginsburg who remains one of
the courts leading liberals and Antonin
Scalia one of its longtime conservative
pillars were both confirmed with support
from more than 95 senators the
Constitution gives senators the right to
offer advice and consent but for most of
us history they deferred to the
president when they blocked a nominee it
was for ethical or legal reasons not
ideological ones that changed in 1987 in
Robert Bork's America there is no room
at the inn for blacks and no place in
the Constitution for women and in our
America there should be no seat on the
Supreme Court for Robert Bork the
Senate's liberal lyin Ted Kennedy
greeted Robert Bork's nomination with an
immediate blast portraying the
conservative judicial hero as a
dangerous extremist Bork was up to
replace the swing vote on the court and
tilt it in a conservative direction
abortion rights and civil rights groups
mobilized my position works professorial
answers in hearings did not dispel the
image that he was detached from modern
society six Republicans joined all but
two Democrats to deny the confirmation
conservatives coined the term borked to
mean partisan savaging of a nominee
something Clarence Thomas's supporters
say happened to him when Anita Hill
accused him of sexual harassment I felt
that I had to tell the truth I could not
keep silent in an era before the me2
movement a bank of male senators reacted
skeptically and Thomas was confirmed in
a 52 to 48 vote after he insisted even
raising the issue was offensive
I've been harmed my family's been harmed
I've been harmed worst and I have ever
been harmed in my life the bork and
Thomas nominations elevated the partisan
stakes which meant would-be justices
learn to say nothing interesting or
revealing that pressure groups might
seize on and exploit
but partisanship was always close to the
surface or plainly visible this is the
greatest honor of my life as in the 2016
nomination of Merrick garland the GOP
Senate intent on denying President
Barack Obama the chance to shift the
court leftward refused to give garland
even a hearing I think it's up to Mitch
McConnell and everybody else to stop it
it's called delay delay delay the chance
to pick a conservative justice energized
Republicans and president Trump filled
the vacancy with Neel Gorsuch confirmed
with just 54 votes after Republican
majority leader Mitch McConnell
eliminated the ability of senators to
block a nomination that could not get 60
votes Thank You mr. chairman like Bork
spread Cavanaugh would replace a swing
vote Anthony Kennedy and cement the
courts conservative majority for decades
whatever the outcome of the Cavanaugh
nomination it will go down as another
chapter in this escalating history of
cut and thrust